Antisemitismus hat leider einen Platz in
Deutschland das ist der bittere der
traurige Pfund den wir nicht erst seit
den Anschlägen in Halle seit den
Anschlägen auf diese Synagoge
beispielsweise in Essen oder seid die
Zeit der Diskussion um die Dokumente
haben sondern seit vielen vielen Jahren
können deutsch deutsche Menschen
deutsche Juden nicht offen ihre Religion
zeigen und leben und deswegen müssen wir
viel entschlossen und konsequente gegen
jede Form von Antisemitismus Vorgehen
das ist Polizei und Gerichte gefragt
Antisemitismus als solchen überhaupt zu
erkennen und dann auch konsequent zu
ahnen und zu verfolgen aber es geht auch
uns an uns alle an diese methismus ist
nicht nur ein Problem von Jüdinnen und
Juden sondern insbesondere von der nicht
jüdischen Mehrheitsgesellschaft in
Deutschland und deswegen gilt es hart zu
widersprechen im bekannten im
Freundeskreis wenn dort antisemitische
Äußerungen fallen
mir das einmal konkret heute berichtet
der Tagesspiegel zu antisem ich muss auf
dem Fußballplatz es ging dabei um den
jüdischen Verein makabi Berlin dort
kommt es immer wieder zu Gewalt die
Spieler werden angegriffen ihn wird die
Hand nicht gegeben ihnen wird das Spiel
verweigert vor allem durch überwiegend
muslimisch geprägte Vereine wir haben
natürlich in Deutschland auch ein
Problem mit muslimischen Antisemitismus
und das hat man viele Jahre in
Deutschland teilweise negiert in der
politischen Debatte weil man immer die
Angst hatte dass dadurch auch Übergriffe
auf unsere muslimischen MitbürgerInnen
Mitbürger stattfinden aber es hilft ja
nichts das Problem nicht offen zu
benennen weil nur so kann man dagegen
angehen das Beispiel dass sie aus dem
Tagesspiegel genannt haben ist ein
Positivbeispiel wie es in Zukunft laufen
sollte weil dort ein Schiedsrichter auch
den Mut hatte das entsprechend
anzuzeigen von dem Sportgericht das
hatte für diesen Verein Konsequenzen
zwei der Spieler die das äh getan haben
sind für zwei Jahre gesperrt der Verein
musste eine Geldstrafe zahlen und es
wurden ihm Punkte in der Tabelle
abgezogen also das auch die Strafe
direkt auf dem Fuß folgt das ist ein
positives Beispiel und ich wünsche mir
mehr solches Engagement in unsere
Zivilgesellschaft was sind muss mehr
getan werden wir haben auch vor der
Sendung gesprochen es ist so ein Thema
im Bundestag was muss wirklich konkret
getan werden und da ist ja nicht nur die
Politik gefragt wir sind wir alle
gefragt wir werden morgen im
Bundeskabinett eine 40-seitige nationale
Strategie gegen Antisemitismus auf den
Weg bringen die unsere Antisemitismus
beauftragte dr Felix Klein
erarbeitet hat ich habe durfte die du
vorlesen ist wirklich eine sehr
zielgenaue treffsicherer Analyse der
Lage auf was es ankommt vor allem auch
die Betroffenen Perspektive einzunehmen
wir hatten das beide Dokumenta das ja
nicht nur der Zentralrat der Juden
sondern viele im Vorfeld gewarnt haben
dass sie befürchten wenn sie früher
waren sie zufrieden wie das
aufgearbeitet wurde die Dokumente nein
nein wir sind ja auch die Kunst
ausgestellt worden konnte zumindest
Anfang ja also das ist so ein Symptom
der Antisemitismus Debatte in
Deutschland über viele Jahre hinweg dass
der Vorwürfe Antisemitismus die Debatte
darüber viel mehr Raum einnimmt als der
Antisemitismus selber und wir müssen
endlich mal in der Lage kommen wo wir
das klar und offen benennen und dann
auch Konsequenzen daraus ziehen dass
eben beispielsweise wie bei BDs einer
Anti Israel Organisation die glasklar
nach allen Definitionen antisemitisch
agiert dass die keine staatlichen
Zuwendungen auch mittelbar bekommt und
deswegen haben wir ja 2019 im Deutschen
Bundestag fraktionsübergreifen einen
entsprechenden Beschluss gefasst das war
nicht einfach zu verhandeln haben auch
nicht alle Abgeordnete für gestimmt und
jetzt ist es eben wichtig drauf zu
gucken dass solche Beschlüsse auch durch
und umgesetzt werden oder das
Betätigungsverbot der Hisbollah in
Deutschland eine Terrororganisation war
über Jahre hinweg sozusagen mehr oder
weniger geduldet und ich erwarte jetzt
Verfassungsschutz und auch von
Sicherheitsbehörden dass sie das
konsequent um und durchsetzen und das
ist in der Schweiz sehr gut
beispielsweise konsequenter umgesetzt
das was Herr Strasser jetzt fordert
ich weiß nicht ob es ob die Problemlage
gleich ist wie in Deutschland
historische Hintergrund hier was sicher
ist das bin ich froh dass es ansprech
das eben auch ein importierten
Antisemitismus gibt und dass das wurde
lange tabuisiert aber es gibt nicht nur
den es gibt natürlich auch eine der in
der deutschen Bevölkerung schon
vorhanden war allerdings muss ich die
Deutschen schon ein bisschen Schutz
nehmen ich meine es gab in der
Geschichte habe es gesagt ich bin
Historiker auch viele andere Länder wo
der Antisemitismus prägend war
Deutschland sie kennen den Fall
ja vor um 1900 herum diese ganzen die
Debatten gab es andere so auch also es
ist das ist eine
Box nicht also der vergleichen dass das
Problem in Deutschland erst seit 2015
mit der Flüchtlingswelle da ist das
definitiv nicht das betrifft alle
Gesellschaft
ich kann nicht sagen ich lege nur da den
Finger rein und negiere das in Halle ein
recht Terrorist zwei Menschen erschossen
hat versucht hat in eine Synagoge
vollbesetze Synagoge einzudringen und
Menschen umzubringen das war eben kein
Muslim aber das zu adressieren heißt ja
nicht dass ich das andere Problem
negiere oder das sogenannte Israel
Kritik also getarnt unter Kritik an der
israelischen Regierungspolitik
Antisemitismus stattfindet auch
intellektuellen greisen das überhaupt
erstmal zu adressieren
nein nein nein
wichtig den Unterschied zu machen aber
sie werden das selber nicht erlebt oder
keine Erlebnis ich habe aber
Gesellschaftsschichten der hat
sicherlich alle gesellschaftlichen dass
es noch mal was ganz anderes haben wir
auch eine historische Verantwortung aber
es ist tatsächlich ich habe da
persönlich keine Erfahrung muss aber
auch sagen man muss auch nicht zu allem
was sagen können und das ist absolut
nicht ein Thema wo ich
sozusagen qualifiziert den Kollegen
irgendwas sagen könnte von daher das ist
ein super wichtiges Thema ich glaube
immer Sport gesprochen Sport kann in dem
Bereich ganz viel leisten Vorurteile
abbauen auch
Ressentiments abbauen aber gut dass das
Thema jetzt politisch behandelt wird